[Music]
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning it seems there is a little
seasonal cheer within the conservative
party boris johnson is facing anger from
his own mps after hastily enforcing a
switch to his plan b for covered
restrictions all this as the row over an
alleged rule-breaking christmas party at
number 10 continues the health secretary
sergeant javid was heckled by tory
backbenchers as he outlined his plans to
combat the threat from omicron we'll be
sitting down and sitting down with him
together in just a few moments time but
also ahead on the programme the england
rugby union coach eddie jones uh well
he'll be joining us to discuss his new
book revealing the secrets behind his
success also ahead
[Music]
it's a rich man's world
why this year's hit pantomime is a
muslim take on a christmas classic it is
thursday the 9th of december
a credibility crisis conservative
pressure on the pm over his switch to
plan b and that christmas party ride
anyone who says there wasn't a party but
knew about it and said in parliament
there was no party it has mislead
apartment and that is a serious charge
and you cannot continue in the highest
office in the land if you've done that
a covered crash the nhs pass app goes
offline following the announcement it'll
become mandatory for some english venues
next week
basement blues the conservatives admits
another illegal christmas party took
place this time at their head office
last december
royal connection the trial of galen
maxwell hears how she and jeffrey
epstein visited the queen's bowel model
estate
as for the weather rain spreading in
from the west after a fine and frosty
start in places
[Music]
morning all and it is the morning after
the day before but it is
unlikely boris johnson is waking up with
a clear head an apology over a leaked
video showing number 10 staff laughing
about an alleged rule-breaking party and
a hasty switch to plan b to stave off
the spread of the omicron variant well
those have done little to quell the
discontent among his own backbenchers
the health secretary was himself heckled
by tory mps as he outlined the measures
in the commons we'll be hearing from him
in just a moment but first let's remind
you as to the new rules for england
well from tomorrow face masks will be
required in more public settings
including theaters and cinemas
from monday people will be asked to work
from home where possible
next wednesday the nhs covert pass will
also be required for nightclubs indoor
unseated venues with more than 500
people unseated outdoor venues with more
than 4 000 people and any event with
more than 10 000 attending uh well
overnight the nhs app crashed for
several hours as people tried to access
their vaccine certificates
but the prime minister says that parties
and nativity plays should still go ahead
so long as the guidance is followed
here's our chief political correspondent
john craig
we will be introducing mandatory
certification
based on vaccines or tests
shouts of disgraceful and resign as
sajid javid announced covid plan b in
the commons
not from opposition mps but from
conservative backbenchers a warning of a
big tory rebellion and mp's vote on the
measures next week
in a 24-hour u-turn boris johnson
triggered covid curbs including working
from home face masks in more places and
vaccine passports for nightclubs and
large events
it's now the proportionate and the
responsible thing to move to plan b in
england while continuing to work closely
with our colleagues in the devolved
administrations so we slow the spread of
the virus
but despite an apology and an inquiry
the prime minister finds himself
engulfed in a scandal over a downing
street party that has led to the charge
that he's taking the public for fools
a sky news poll suggests only 12 percent
think he's telling the truth about the
party it is quite clear that the prime
minister has lied regularly and
repeatedly about the downing street
parties and sent his own ministers out
to lie on his behalf this has undermined
public trust and confidence in the prime
minister in his government but even
worse in the public health measures and
public health message at a critical time
after a tearful resignation by number 10
spokeswoman allegra stratton who
appeared in a video joking about the
party i went home
senior tories also turned up the heat on
the pm
anyone who says there wasn't a party but
knew about it and said in parliament
there was no party it has misled
parliament and that is a serious charge
and you cannot continue in the highest
office in the land if you've done that
the problem facing the prime minister as
he brings in new rules on face masks and
vaccine passports is that mps including
many on his own side and now saying how
can he expect the public to obey the new
rules when people here inside this
building appear to have been breaking
the rules
there's no danger of the government
losing next week's vote on plan b since
labour has pledged to support the
measures thanks everybody thank you but
the pm is facing a major crisis over his
credibility and even calls to resign
john craig sky news
uh well overnight the conservatives have
admitted they did host another illegal
party last christmas an event was held
by the team running the campaign for the
conservative candidate for london mayor
sean bailey
that party was held at the conservative
party headquarters in december last year
in a statement conservative officials
said they were aware of what they called
an unauthorized social gathering in the
basement and that disciplinary action
had been taken
very pleased to say that we're joined
once again on the programme by the
health secretary sergeant javed mr javid
great to see you this morning um and of
course there is plenty to talk about in
terms of parties but let's let's start
on your briefing with that the changes
to the public health strategy clearly
there is an awful lot of concern in
government about the spread of omicron
right now
why are we so concerned well since
this new variant our strategy has been
to buy time time to assess it and also
to build our protective defenses in
recent days we've started learning more
about the variant and one of those
things we've learned is that it spreads
very very quickly it spreads faster than
any other code variant we've seen so far
it's doubling time that's the number of
days it takes the number of affections
take to double in the community we
estimate is between two and a half to
three days which would mean at that rate
by the end of this month we could hit
about a million infections in the
community uh throughout the uk and we've
always been clear that should the data
change and should should it move in the
wrong direction and and it looked like
that the nhs might come under
unsustainable pressure remember what
that would mean we wouldn't be able to
get emergency care not just for covert
you know give a car accident or anything
like that we would act and implement
plan b now i don't enjoy doing that no
one does you know it has a it's a very
difficult thing for many people asking
them to work from home or wearing face
busts and things it's a it's a real
impact on our liberties but i hope that
most people will understand that by
taking some dissatisfaction now we can
potentially avoid uh action later and
then just on that our vaccines and our
anti-virals also remain a very important
part of our defenses the the key one i i
suspect and all that is potentially we
do not yet know whether or not the
boosters plus plan b
will in and of themselves be enough to
to halt the spread of omicron if they're
not what next look we we we don't have
all the answers in omicron yet we've
been very clear about that's not just
does it throughout the world many
countries are still trying to learn more
but what we do know is by implementing
plan b so the rules around you know
working from home the the face mask
rules the the rule around the covert uh
passport that that will mean that we can
slow uh the incursion of this slow this
is the spread of this and it buys us
time to build our defenses and and that
the booster is key because although it's
possible and again it's possibly that
the the efficacy of vaccines may be
impacted by omicron and there's some
data to suggest that it is still the
case that by boosting you're going to
get a lot more protection than otherwise
we're doing incredibly well as a country
with boosters over 20 million
it's all accepted but but it is the case
isn't it that over the christmas period
there will be increased mixing unless of
course there is a change to the plans
for christmas that is in and of itself
likely to lead to to increase spread
is it the case that you know come
january we could be looking at even more
significant measures being brought in no
i i hope not and i think the the action
we've taken now it's very decisive i
think it's going to make a big
difference and as i say it's it's not
something that anyone would do likely
has a real impact on people will be
difficult for many people but i think
that and i hope most people will would
understand is better to take this action
now
than to see the the rate of spread
increase
is the government considering mandatory
vaccination i mean the prime minister
did appear to hint at that when he
suggested a a national conversation
about mandatory vaccination what's the
truth of that no we've got i mean i've
got no interest in mandatory vaccination
apart from the high risk settings in the
nhs and social care which we've already
set out that we will legislate for uh
other than that if you talk about
universal mandatory vaccination i think
ethically it's wrong but also at a very
practical level it just wouldn't work
you know being getting vaccinated has to
be a positive decision it feels like we
can park that one then but just in terms
of the hospitality sector slightly away
from your brief but will we see
additional support for hospitality
because they are already starting to
lose money as a result of these plan b
changes well the measures we we've taken
in
under the you know the plan b uh
although they they have an impact
they're designed to have the a minimal
impact so whether it's wearing uh face
masks uh exempting hospitality from
certain measures on the kobe past
there's this sounds like a new for more
financial support for well not
we'll keep that under review but the the
measures are designed to have this
minimum impact let us let us discuss the
events of the past couple of days we
were expecting to see you sitting in
that chair yesterday morning k burley
was very very upset that you didn't
appear
why wasn't there a government minister
on the media rounds yesterday well i i
didn't appear because i saw that video
the video you just played again
uh it upset me it upset a lot of people
i think across the country it upset the
prime minister did you refuse to come on
yesterday no it wasn't about refu i
spoke to my colleagues in number 10 and
i said look
we actually agreed that it's best to
have some time to to respond to the
video in the way the prime minister has
now by ordering an investigation by the
cabinet secretary and so i think the
idea was just to give them space to
react but i'm pleased the prime minister
has asked for an investigation and i and
i can see also why so many people would
have been upset by that video totally
but will you now be the first minister
to accept on a balance of probabilities
that an event probably did take place in
december on that date and that rules
were probably broken the truth is i
don't know i i i the i have received
assurances like the prime minister has
that all rules will follow throughout
the pandemic at all times who is
providing those reassurances because we
have heard this from government
ministers sitting where you are all this
week we've heard it countless times from
the prime minister i have been told i
have been reassured who's saying i'm not
i'm not going to get into names but
senior people have assured me that rules
have been followed but i also think the
people wouldn't think to check this the
the prime minister i think has acted
completely correctly yesterday to order
an investigation and to find out you
know what may or may not have happened
and to have that investigation done by
the cabinet secretary who's free to look
wherever he wishes speak to whoever he
wants and look at any potential event
that may or may not have happened but we
saw the prime minister yesterday pmq's
accusing keir starman of playing
politics and all of this the prime
minister at any point over the last
seven days could have opened up the door
to his office popped outside asked
people what went on on that day and
discovered for themselves the reason he
hasn't done so you and i both know this
to be the case is that it's politically
expedient for the prime minister to not
know what went on in number 10 if that's
not playing politics with the situation
what it no i don't accept that and the
reason is because what we heard from the
prime minister yesterday is that he's
asked for an investigation by the
cabinet secretary the campus secretary
has a lot of authority and he can speak
to whoever he wishes and find out what
really happened i think the best way to
to to look into this is to get the
cabinet secretary use all his authority
to find out what really but presumably
the cabinet secretary was one of those
reassuring the prime minister that no
rules had been broken i mean surely that
would have been the first person he
would have asked well i i i'm again i'm
not i wasn't even in government at that
time so i don't know who may have given
the pm that reassurance or not but i
know i think it is important of the this
investigation that's going on because
he's either been misled or someone has
lied to him because as you noted the
video itself pretty clearly demonstrates
two very senior figures in downing
street one of whom has now departed
conceding that a party took place
accepting the fact that rules were
probably broken and more than that then
going on to war game a potential
response the video is prima facie
evidence that a party took place i'm
just wondering why the prime minister
has taken so long to reach that
conclusion i'm sure the cabinet
secretary would take into account what's
on that video the people that were in
that room at the time but it's right the
the cabinet secretary is given the time
to do that and get to the bottom of this
but just in terms of that investigation
by the cabinet secretary what what faith
can any of us have that the prime
minister will follow the results of that
investigation the last time there was an
investigation by a member of the senior
a senior member of the civil service the
head of ethics for the civil service
into pretty patel and bullying the prime
minister read it and then discarded it
well the
investigation is taking place i don't
want to preempt the outcome of it but i
know that your simon case is a very
professional very serious person
was the head of ethics for the service
let's see what comes out of the
investigation
there is a pattern of behavior here why
is the investigation only focusing on
the party that took place in downing
street on the 18th not the party that
took place on the 13th of november in
his flat not the party that took place
on november the 27th at which the prime
minister spoke the party that took place
at the department for education the
party that took place at cchq why is the
investigation only focused on the one
thing that the prime minister can
guarantee he wasn't attending it's not
my understanding is that simon case and
his team can look at any aspect of any
potential event that may or may not
happen at number 10 including
my understanding again is that he will
be looking into the uh what happened at
the department of education as well why
did allegra stratton resign
honestly i don't know and uh i i i do
know allegra i think she's an
outstanding uh spokesperson she's done
some fantastic work on on the cop
recently
that conference um and i think just by
listening to her statement yesterday uh
i think she felt bad about you know what
had happened and and the way things look
well she apologized for the joke on
which basis why is ed oatfield still in
his point is still in his position he
was there he was joking why is jacob
rees-mogg still leader of the house he
was joking and the
institute for fiscal studies event that
happened the past couple of days
look i i think that we should just let
this investigation happen and and get to
the facts and simon case is the person
to do that do you not understand though
that the level of frustration that there
is in this government at the moment
because on the one hand we have been
told for over a week now that no party
took place yesterday downing street
refused to repeat that denial the only
thing that has changed is that video has
emerged which shows that a party took
place and that rules were broken that is
the only thing that has changed i mean
are you taking the public for fools in
all of this the reason presumably
allegra stratton resigned it's not
because of the joke but because the
government has been caught in the
cover-up
i i just said to you at the start of
this
but you asked me why didn't i appear why
wasn't i sitting here yesterday it's
because i saw that video i found it very
upsetting uh to to see what was on that
video that they're laughing the
sniggering and things i think most
people did across the country and and
and that's the way i reacted and now the
prime minister has reacted by asking for
an investigation i'm pleased he's done
that but of course of course i
understand
how people feel uh what they might think
and what they're seeing and i do think
we need to get to the bottom of it and
the way to do that is to have this
investigation that the campus secretary
is leading do you though accept that
there is a real problem in terms of
trust in this government the simple fact
is that no one believes you no one
believes you when you say that there was
no party number 10 not you specifically
but the government that no rules were
broken fewer than one in 10 believe
number 10's claim that no party took
place in downing street and this follows
on from a number of other occasions over
the past 12 24 months where the
government have said x is going to
happen and then it doesn't or promise
why and then it doesn't appear i mean
the list of occasions on which this
government has performed a u-turn free
school meals the reopening of primary
schools mandatory face coverings and
shops face mastering schools a levels
second lockdown furlough extension
canceling christmas the northern ireland
protocol vaccine passport you performed
a u-turn on all of this isn't it
objectively reasonable for people now to
distrust everything that this government
i think honestly i think it's it's
unfair to really conflate all of that i
understand the anger about the video as
i've
shared with you my own anger and concern
about that but the the other issues that
you mentioned i mean these are all
important issues but you know for
example you just mentioned you know
covered passports or
face masks and things it is right that
we have a flexible response uh to the
pandemic all of this made your job when
when
things when when things have uh improved
the pandemic as we saw we made the right
decisions to open up in the summer we've
been really fortunate as a country with
the work the nhs has done around our
vaccination effort fantastic effort
we've got more people vaccinating most
other countries but all of this doesn't
make you successful
well i'm just i'm getting on with my job
and the important thing is right here
and now as far as i'm concerned is that
the pandemic is still there uh we need
to keep boosting and building our
defenses we need to learn more about new
variants and we need to make the
difficult decisions to help protect the
country and that's what i'm going to be
focused on and can i just finally say if
i made it if any of your viewers if they
get the call from the nhs to get
vaccinated particularly the booster you
know please please turn up and roll up
your sleeve and get protected well we
saw the efforts that you went to with
john craig i'm sure the public will be
paying you he's well boosted indeed uh
health secretary thanks for joining us
thank you
well let's quickly get the papers take
on the story starting with the ft
uh boris johnson adopts plan b to check
varys as anger festers over parties
the eye says that boris johnson johnson
rushed in new covered restrictions in
england after an outcry over downing
street staff uh joking about breaching
lockdown restrictions
prime minister is taking the public for
fools uh the metro's headline it says
the prime minister is facing growing
calls to quit
the telegraph says that boris johnson
has told people to work from home yet
said they can still have office
christmas parties prompting suggestions
the new rules were somewhat illogical
and the guardian reports the labour
claim sorry reports labor claims that mr
johnson has lost moral authority
that's still to come on the programme
this morning well as the government
introduces further covert restrictions
in england we'll be discussing how we're
doing in the fight against omicron
has the government mishandled
allegations of a downing street party or
seen offered crisis we'll be discussing
that the former dining street director
of communications jonathan haslam
and we'll also hear claims that the nhs
has been pushed to breaking point by
demands for child mental health services
[Music]
over the next few days anyone working in
an office running a city centre business
or going to a concert in england will
see some pretty substantial changes
skies shinki maruriki has been taking a
closer look
for almost 44 years this pie shop in
reading has been dishing out handmade
delights
after struggling through the pandemic
the news customers will once again be
asked to work from home comes as yet
another blow to business
each day we get a phone call for
cancellations we've had almost 150
council in the last few days at the
moment the people who are in the offices
yes we do get them in
especially in our little retail shop for
takeaway
obviously that will slow that down
dramatically at lunch times the
government's plan b brought in to stop
the spread of the omicron variant will
also see mandatory mask wearing in
places like theaters and cinemas while
vaccine passports will be needed for
nightclubs and large venues
from next week clubbing in places like
here leicester square will look very
different drinking dancing and having a
good time will come with a slice of
precaution in the form of a mandatory
vaccine possible
the new rules were supported by these
concert goers in north london why not
just get it it costs nothing
there you go it's keeping people safe
i'm vaccinated i think everyone should
be that goes to a gig i've got some
underlying health conditions as well so
i think knowing that everything's in
place it's a lot better for me and my
anxiety so i feel a lot more confident
going out now but the chief executive
for the night time industries
association says restrictions are a
hammer blow for the sector we're in a
very fragile state and we need as much
support as possible and that comes you
know both from a financial position as
well as a confidence position from
government we've done an amazing job
since the 19th of july and the
government should have confidence that
we have delivered everything we said
we'd deliver in terms of these
mitigations so further restrictions are
a real blow for us as an industry
it's usually a time for celebration but
with covert cases on the rise the
festivities we used to take for granted
will look very different shinki marikay
sky news
let's bring against guys charlotte lomas
who's with commuters at gerard's cross
in buckinghamshire morning charlotte
you've got to imagine that plenty of
those who'll be getting on the train
this morning might not be getting on the
train come monday
that's right neil that's i'll be
actually talking to some of the
commuters here in general's cross as
they are running for their train this
morning many of them won't be doing that
come monday morning there's a real mix
of mood among the commuters here some
that i've been talking to are angry at
having to return to working from home
others just feel essentially that it's
the rules and that they will have to
comply despite being disappointed many
people have just got back into the swing
of office life and enjoying
doing that there's also the business
side to all of this many businesses are
angry at having to take that step back
and some unions uh calling for furlough
to be reintroduced to help support
those people but really
as of plan b coming back this will be
the main change affecting most people
with the government ordering many of us
to return to working from home and it
really is to try and stop that rapid
spread of the variant on the crom we
know we've heard from the scientific
advisory group sage
warning that the doubling time of this
virus is two to three days so you can
really clearly see that things could get
very bad very quickly and that's why the
government wants to impose these
restrictions
thanks very much indeed
uh well let's ourselves take a quick
look at the latest daily covert data
and there have been 51
342 new cases recorded in the last 24
hours another 161 deaths have been
reported within 28 days of a positive
test that brings the total number of
deaths in the uk to 145
987
meanwhile 23 512 people received their
first dose of a vaccine while 28
375 receive their second that takes the
total number of second doses to
46.6 million
what are boosters third jabs well 391
050 of those were given in the latest
24-hour period
meaning the total number of booster and
third doses is ahead of 21.3 million
also this morning the australian deputy
prime minister has tested positive for
coronavirus just days after a visit to
the uk
barnaby joyce was forced to go into
isolation after arriving in the united
states mr joyce told sky news australia
he may have contracted the virus while
he was in britain
look in the uk it's
i must admit it's crowded crowded and
christmas shopping and
um you know it's a
you wouldn't know there was a
pandemic on in many areas of the uk
people just shoulder to shoulders and so
you know there's
a heap of areas you could possibly get
it
despite a major operation by the u.s
coast guard a woman has died after her
car crashed into the river near niagara
falls
search and rescue teams did manage to
reach the car just meters from the edge
a body of a woman in her 60s was
recovered from the vehicle
the new zealand government has revealed
plans to stop young people smoking from
2027 it plans to make it illegal for
anyone aged 14 to ever buy tobacco in
their life now if it comes into force it
would be one of the most strict
anti-smoking laws in the world
time for a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
it will be calmer than recently but rain
will spread from the west on
strengthening winds currently mostly
calm dry and clear with apache frost but
there are some mainly coastal showers in
the north the west of ireland is pretty
wet the uk will stay mostly fine through
the morning with early showers becoming
confined to northern scotland but
northern ireland and the south west will
turn wet ireland will see the rain in
the west clearing into northern and
eastern parts
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
coming up after the break we'll be
discussing the fight against omicron and
the new covert restrictions in england
with the epidemiologist andrew hayward
that's coming next
[Music]
welcome back the health secretary says
he was upset when he first saw a leaked
video of downing street staff laughing
about an alleged party held during
lockdown boris johnson has apologized
for the incident last december but
conservative mps have joined the
opposition and demanding a further
explanation
i saw that video i found it very
upsetting uh to to see what was on that
video that they're laughing they're
sniggering and things i think most
people did across the country and and
and that's the way i reacted and now the
prime minister has reacted by asking for
an investigation i'm pleased he's done
that but of course of course i
understand
how people feel uh what they might think
and what they're seeing and i do think
we need to get to the bottom of it and
the way to do that is to have this
investigation that the cabinet secretary
is leading
well sanjay javid also warned that the
uk could see a million cases of the
omicron strain of coronavirus he says
we're still learning about how the
latest variant spreads
in recent days we've started learning
more about the variant and one of those
things we've learned is that it spreads
very very quickly it spreads faster than
any other code variant we've seen so far
it's doubling time that's the number of
days it takes the number of affections
take to double in the community we
estimate is between two and a half to
three days which would mean at that rate
by the end of this month we could hit
about a million infections in the
community uh throughout the uk
our political correspondent rob powell
is on duty for us this morning good to
see you rob um well there are two
aspects to all of this but both of them
piling pressure on the government
clearly the concerns about the omicron
variant but no matter how much we try
the government tries to bat off this to
a cabinet secretary investigation there
are still plenty of questions to ask
about a party that frankly everyone now
assumes took place and everyone assumes
broke the rules yeah i think on those
sort of points around health policy if
you like i thought an alarming picture
being painted by the health secretary
and when you asked whether we could see
more restrictions in january after
christmas mixing all he said to that was
well i hope not which isn't terribly
reassuring interesting as well coming
pretty close to ruling out compulsory
vaccination after the pm appeared to
float that idea last night so quite
strong um on that um i think on the
issue of the party the effect that these
investigations and calling an
investigation um from by the cabinet
secretary have is they act like a bit of
a political fire blanket for ministers
facing interviews because any time they
get questions about it they can just say
look we need to wait for the
investigation to play out and whilst he
did go fairly far and saying he was
upset by the sniggering in that video on
the actual facts and what that video
really does seem to suggest that
something was going on that night in
number 10 that was not completely within
the rules he just wouldn't be drawn on
it saying that he didn't know why
allegra stratton um had resigned when i
think even though she didn't make
reference to the party in her statement
it seems pretty clear as day to most
people that if everything was above
board on december the 18th there would
have probably been no need for her to
resign so really not giving much at all
on that and just saying wait for the
inquiry the political danger for the
prime minister though is that this
morning there are reports um or
confirmation from the conservative party
of another
event that took place in tory hq there
are accusations of an event that the
prime minister went to of parties going
on in the prime ministerial flat as well
and if more details around them come out
that's when it starts to get very very
sticky for the government certainly does
rob for no thanks very much indeed
well as we've been reporting the prime
minister says that the spreads of the
omicron variant will lead to a big rise
in the number of people in hospital and
therefore the number of lives lost
official figures suggest that cases are
doubling every three days worrying
indeed joining us now andrew hayward
director of ucl's institute of
epidemiology and healthcare and a member
of nerf tag the new emerging respiratory
virus threats advisory group good to see
you again this morning andrew um let us
just start with that which we heard from
the prime minister yesterday uh the move
to plan b coming perhaps slightly
earlier than some had anticipated what
do you make of it
well i think the virus is moving very
fast so it's important that we react to
that
fast um as you say this this doubling
time of two to three times but
every two to three days rather is is is
very fast and if we think about we've
had very high levels of um the delta
variant for about six months now but
it's been at a sort of steady rate i
think the scary thing about this is that
because it's going up so fast you'll get
a very large peak uh and it's a bit like
if you think of uh you know a month's
worth of rain falling in in a few days
that leads to flooding and it's a
similar type of scenario and so
unfortunately we can reduce that by
reducing social mixing and allow time to
slow the virus down and get vaccine into
more people's arms
i mean
as you've mentioned there is still so
much about omicron that we we do not yet
know but on the basis of that which we
do is plan b sufficient to slow the
spread
it will slow the spread it's not going
to turn it around
i think
you would need much much more
severe restrictions to turn it around
but i think what the encouraging thing
is that we've started to see through
some of the laboratory data is that that
third dose
of vaccine
is is really providing much better
immunity
whereas just with the two doses it's
it's not really so good so
so so this idea of slowing it down first
with what we can do quickly which is
this
the more social distancing not going to
work
um if you don't have to not going on
public transport to to go to work when
you don't have to that will make a
difference
um i mean i think it's very difficult to
predict um
whether that's going to be enough
but i think it's an essential
first move here
uh andrew then just just in terms though
again of
that which we do not know about about
omicron um
in terms of the symptoms that it causes
there is some data that suggests that it
may well be milder than other variants
but
that increased transmissibility alone
will mean increased hospitalizations and
and increased deaths
yes i mean i think that's that's right
and
a i think we shouldn't
overplay our knowledge about the
severity at the moment um the so far
it's been
mainly in a young adult population we
haven't really seen what it's going to
do in an older population
so so that's one thing but then even if
the severity was reduced to a moderate
or to even quite a large extent uh if
you've got many fold more cases at one
time than you would have done then
that's when you're going to get this
flood of cases uh in the nhs and the nhs
doesn't have a huge amount of capacity
for example you know if we compare
ourselves to germany we've got less than
half the amount of hospital beds so we
haven't got that much to play with
andrew hayward great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for joining
us
now the allegations of illegal
conservative christmas parties continue
this morning uh the party has admitted
an event was held by the team running
the campaign for the conservative
candidate for london mayor sean bailey
at party headquarters last december uh
but are they now getting on top of this
scandal uh johnny is on the program
jonathan haslam former dining street
communications director for john major
uh jonathan lovely to see you again um
let us start shall we with the with the
firefighting strategy that appears to be
uh taking the government at the moment
has the prime minister's position been
made more secure by the announcement of
an investigation into a party that you
know just a couple of days ago the prime
minister was insisting insisting did not
happen and that no rules have been
broken
good morning neil
i think he's bought some extra time but
the strategy still seems to me to be one
that's being made up on the hoof and
i'll be very surprised if uh at the end
of this we're not seeing one or two
other people departing from downing
street and burnishing their cvs over the
christmas period it really doesn't seem
to stack up too much
there has to be a very clear explanation
from simon case about what happened
the public certainly isn't in a mood to
accept
sophistry around how you define a party
and how you define a gathering
and some sort of clever wheeze that
might get the government out of trouble
you may recall that there was some time
ago when both boris johnson and rishi
sunak were tested positive for kovid and
there was a brief hours period when
suddenly downing street and uh number
11 and 12 were designated as areas where
actually you could try out uh not
isolating and that's crashed to earth
fairly quickly
this is pretty serious stuff because the
prime minister's on the house
in the house he said uh on the record
that there wasn't a party he has i said
that's how he was being briefed
but the public must be fed up to the
back teeth with all of this nonsense
there are too many serious things
happening with kovid that you've just
been discussing with another expert
as well as an international sphere when
we see a hundred thousand troops on
ukraine's border and we want our
government to be able to concentrate
full-heartedly on that not the
shenanigans of people who think they can
break rules with impunity and joke about
it on video
so the strategies for me seems to be at
least a week late and only about 10
percent of what should be done
jonathan you you suggested there may
well be more resignations to follow that
of allegra stratton and i think there'll
be plenty of people who who agree with
you but just in terms of of of her
resignation do you accept you know her
statement on on her front steps
yesterday at face value that she
resigned because of the joke that she
was making or do you feel as others do
that allegra stratton has resigned
because she was pictured in a video
which confirms that the party did take
place and that senior figures in number
10 knew that it had probably broken
rules
we won't know entirely until somebody
speaks to her and um as you and i
followed followed politics had been
associated with it for a very long time
we tend to be cynical and flinty-hearted
about this
while i saw that i'll show you a kind of
nice
while i saw that you know allegra was
clearly distressed on her doorstep i
also noted that a statement given in
that fashion uh without the opportunity
to put a question to her was very clear
so there was some manipulation going on
in that regard as well so
where we are at the moment is a
completely dysfunctional downing street
with nobody seeming to have a grip chaos
is not a management theory that you can
apply in government and the public at
this very difficult time really needs to
know there is strong determined
integrity and
intellectually coherent arguments for
asking us to undergo yet more
restrictions on our ways of life and we
can understand it we will go with it but
at the moment the prime minister is
resting heavily on
witty and valance and their credibility
and the needs of the national health
service uh this isn't tenable and
actually i do wait to see uh when the
government in terms of its cabinet is
actually going to step up and start
holding the prime minister to account it
might be promising to paris but he's not
a dictator that appears that he seems to
have impunity at the moment there are
too many questions still an answer neil
indeed and just just briefly if you can
how difficult is the job of government
when as it appears that the opinion poll
suggesting that people are just now
starting not to believe what this
government says anymore
it's very difficult because you're
asking people to do things that
naturally they don't want to do and
we're a pretty long suffering nation
overall and we will go and accept some
of these uh
restrictions on our lives but there will
come a point when actually it'll show as
it already is in the polls and the
politicians will start to wake up so
watch for the chief whip going into
number 10 to have a quiet word with the
prime minister watch for graham brady
saying actually you need to step up this
game is just not good enough you need to
change it you know it's a bit like
manchester united under oligarch sooner
or later you've got to change or you
accept that you're just going to be in a
team of mediocrity which is entirely
wrong for a country of our standing
and entirely wrong for a team like
manchester united uh jonathan haslam
good to see you this morning thanks very
much for joining us
now uh pictures shown at the trial of
galen maxwell show her with the
disgraced billionaire jeffrey epstein at
the queen's belmoral estate uh the
pictures appear to show the extent of
maxwell's closeness with epstein who
took his own life while awaiting sex
trafficking charges our u.s
correspondent martha kellner has the
detail
they appear on some of the photos like
any other loving couple documenting a
life of luxury lived together a ski trip
a tight embrace even a visit it seems to
the queen's balmoral estate pictured in
the same spot where her majesty has been
photographed
but these pictures including those taken
aboard jeffrey epstein's private plane
and now evidence in a sex trafficking
trial which could see glenn maxwell
spend the rest of her life in prison the
prosecution argues they show not only
romantic partners but partners in crime
they were found on cds and hard drives
seized during a police raid of epstein's
new york mansion stored inside wardrobes
and a safe
also found was this advert apparently
created by maxwell calling for a massage
therapist much of epstein's abusing is
said to have centered around massages
the prosecution's case is that glenn
maxwell and jeffrey epstein's lives were
very much intertwined that while they
may have started out as boyfriend and
girlfriend glenn maxwell soon became
much more than that one witness
described her as epstein's second in
command
david rogers a former pilot for epstein
was asked where ms maxwell sat in the
hierarchy she would be number two he
said below whom the prosecutor asked he
responded jeffrey epstein
the prosecution is expected to rest its
case today having perhaps saved their
strongest witness for last annie farmer
is the only alleged victim testifying to
have waved her anonymity it will then be
the defense's turn to argue that glenn
maxwell is not the handmaiden to sex
abuse she's being portrayed as martha
kellner sky news new york
stay right where you are after the break
i'll be discussing those claims that the
demand for child mental health services
is pushing the health service to
breaking point that's next
[Music]
now mps on the health and social care
committee and a panel of experts say
that mental health provision is being
pushed to breaking point by growing
demands for mental health care for
youngsters and children joining us now
on the programme professor dame jane
daker who chairs that expert panel
assessing the government's progress in
child mental health and professor daker
great to have you on the programme this
morning um i i wonder if we can just
start with them with a with a very
general question
just how stretched how overstretched in
fact is mental health care for our young
people
well mental health care is overstretched
for all of our people um the expert
panel that that i chair looked at mental
health care in the round and it included
children and young people
and what we did was gather evidence both
from uh patients and also from uh
doctors and and and other health care
workers and we compared that to uh to
government data and other data that we
could find and we gave uh ratings for uh
the mental health pledges the government
had made and and found that in all areas
it requires improvement and that
includes
children and and young people
um
and the main
problem was that access to mental health
care wasn't
uh
wasn't as good as it should have been or
wasn't as good as it had been promised
to be
and also when young people have a crisis
that crisis is not dealt with as
efficiently as it should be so
it is worrying
it's not only worrying for children
though our expert panel reports show
that it's worrying for everybody with
mental health um
mental health problems
to what extent the professor can can we
generalize and suggest that these
additional pressures on mental health
mental health care provision
flow directly from the pandemic i mean
there can't be one of us that hasn't
over the past you know 18 months had a
bit of a wobble myself included we've
all had to think a little bit more
carefully about our mental health
luckily i work for an organization where
i can pick up the phone and get help if
i need so other people are not quite so
lucky
uh well interestingly um our work judged
pledges to that started to be made
pre-pandemic and what is a bit
disheartening is that the pledges were
not on track to be met before the
pandemic even started so the pandemic
has undoubtedly made things worse it
doesn't uh alter what we found in our in
our work though because uh we
deliberately excluded uh the the
influence of the of the pandemic from
our judgments but there is no doubt that
during the pandemic there has been an
increase in people having uh concerns
about their well-being and there is a
there is a debate
uh about how much of that is actually
legitimate concern um however some of
that concern has gone on to become
significant um mental illness or mental
health problems
it has been some time since i can first
recall the government talking about
parity of esteem between physical health
care and
and mental health care judging by your
report
we are a country mile away from
achieving that goal of parity of esteem
we haven't achieved parity of esteem um
and although a number of the pledges
that have been put in were
very well founded and
uh hoped to achieve parity of esteem
sadly the mental health workforce
doesn't have the skills and and and
expertise amongst amongst its staff to
be able to institute the the treatments
that are necessary
and another pledge which wasn't met was
the idea of having physical health
checks for patients with mental illness
and again that has been met so
uh we have a bit of a way to go to
achieve quality of esteem now this is
not to undermine the sterling efforts of
those that work in mental health
services and indeed those that are
leading the work in mental health
services who've actually done an
extremely good job at working on
improving things it's just that they
came from behind there's a long way to
go to catch up and the pledges that have
been made for the moment are just not
achievable
um professor dame jane dicker chair of
that expert panel evaluating the
government's progress uh against its
commitments to mental health great to
have you on the program this morning
really appreciate it
thank you very much thank you very much
and you lot can stay exactly where you
are still to come we will of course
reflect on that interview with the
health secretary about the move to plan
b somewhat abrupt move to blanby and of
course
those christmas parties but we'll also
be speaking to the labour deputy leader
angela raynor she'll be here well she'll
be phoning us in to give us her take on
the allegations of a party in downing
street and indeed the government's
public health response to omicron all
that coming up after this
[Music]